welcome our animation bronze medal
winner undress Saul off receiving this
award is a tremendous honor and I'm very
grateful to be here with all these great
films and I'd like to thank the academy
for this amazing honor and just this
week that we've had these meetings and
whatnot that have been so inspiring and
really just inspired me to move forward
and keep doing creative work in my
career and there's no way I could have
ever made this film without my amazing
girlfriend sun-hi Yoon who did the
special effects and colored over half of
it and also put up with me bouncing
ideas off of her for months and that
deserves an applause oh also my amazing
composer Cal Blanton Ross who did an
amazing job with the score and with
sound design Hagen I'd like to thank my
mom and dad Peter and Sylvia salif who
are here tonight as well and they've
always encouraged me and supported me
usually for the most part whatever I
wanted to do as well as my brother
Carlos and sister-in-law Jen who have
always been there for me and there to
give me feedback and all that great
stuff so the calarts character animation
department really I feel nurtured our
exploration and trying to find our own
visions and I'd like to thank David and
Jennifer skelly who were my story
teachers and without that class the film
would have never been fleshed out the
way the story would have never turned
out the way it did so I'd like to thank
them for that and then I'd like to thank
the great corny Cole and my animation
teacher Ted tea and Kevin Johnson as
well as my mentor Mike wing I'd also
like to thank Derek Diana Ethan and
Carly who did additional coloring on it
and I'd also like to thank God for
are being on this path of making
animated films that I hope are and will
continue to be inspiring and just fun to
watch for everybody so thank you all
very much